hey guys this is John I've been hanging
out for the past few days here in Oslo
Norway it's been a blast and I had the
pleasure of the other day of going over
to the play Magnus offices here in Oslo
and I'm cutting a little video for their
tactics frenzy app which was recently
released along with of course the play
Magnus app everyone's favorite get to
play Magnus age 5 through I believe is
current age 29
even our video guy Pat has been playing
Magnus he has previously not been much
of a chess enthusiasts but we got them
interested on this trip there's also the
Magnus trainer of course and now they've
got tactics frenzy as well so I was
checking this out a little bit
let's do there's a couple different
modes you can do training and times I'm
gonna go with the times and you get to
choose between easy medium and hard
puzzles or you can do random let's go
for the random get a nice little mix of
positions here and try to talk through
the thought process as well again this
is a main to Queen G to mate
96 definitely comes to mind here of
course you gotta be fast in this and you
can see if you saw them quickly you
build up the time bonus so fortunately
I've got some pretty easy ones so far
early in this from blacks point of view
okay so we have to stop white from
trading this the b-pawn for the C pawn
that's critical here
I think I can just approach with my king
I don't see an issue with that got that
long all right
negative six minus six looks very strong
attacking h5 let's go for it
I'm taking the work is undefended on the
eight Queens hanging what's the deal
here please hang in the night same okay
easy one
take the g7 when the rough and gilt 906
check I'm gonna take the bishop wanna
take the road it's gotta be Knight f6
there's no other moves that make sense
here well recovering BB three check
always got a look at the checks of
course the captures especially the
checks Queen b3 Queenie six that would
be my default idea here the bishop money
for does a good job protecting the
position 93 wins the Queen right keeping
one eye on the time as well can't stop
this pawn
[Music]
it's games wait that's not a king that
should be able to survive here Queen f6
just makes autumn take on h5 and then
Queen at five is made to go back for a
week back Frank
easy easy here
take you for those sunny eggs I was soon
wish upon a three looks really weird in
this position it's gonna lock in on the
side of the board maybe rub d8 that
should probably win peace quiet move
there 93 Jack wins the clean but black
is down material and their queen is
hanging at state items your counters
also a chef down here and 94 made of yes
okay this is a four patterns you know
now for should win a piece due to the
pin
take this guy all right I'll play a time
left
check his nice deflection move if Knight
takes on c1 there is queen d1
let's check wins a piece good pattern to
know that takes B 3 and then Queen d2
Queen B 2 is made what if white plays
can't be won it's the only question
feels like there should even eat there
are not sure ah there's also rook take C
to another check to look at I think it's
proud of you Brooke take C - oh it was
wrong ok that digging my time right
there Knight f6 on a rook like f7 is
forced make three not gonna win the
Queen maybe one so I can take the run
but there's this pawn we can stop it
easily with ignite
stuff is hanging ever takes a ate first
we're taking the fish up it's gotta be
sometimes you can solve these tactical
positions by process of elimination so
it's a good example right there because
you can see five first stalemates I see
none for white rook d1 when I takes d2
Knight takes D to Bishop takes G to
though
let's go over t1 this pattern here
checkmate we've got a minute left
oh no starts counting down the 10 to the
milliseconds Knight f5 meeting want to
open this diagonal towards the black
cape I'm not quite seeing it five looks
very strong I'm gonna risk it nope that
was wrong
this is the queen discovery trying to
build this time back up she's six Knight
f6 g6 I'm not seeing the follow up at
for me I'm gonna try a knight f6 got
that wrong I had a guess though sake
take it check in the rook can't walk
with a queen alright still in this
g7 coming her push all right thank you
six made easy that's a smother made
where is my checkmate here there's so
many discovered checks but there's
probably only one main out there I can
actually last you to have a number of
Broncos alright I got 15 in a row at one
point that was not bad and this looks
like a nice feature to review my
mistakes may not the mode I'm doing it
but yeah no that was fun
I like the interface that was very
smooth play Magnus is not paying me to
say this by the way but just wanted to
take a look at their app but yeah if
you're looking to get better at your
tactics especially if you're on your
phone this could be a nice little app to
use and again there's different
difficulty levels so easy an easy medium
and hard or you can get a nice mix as I
did there with random you can do times
or on times so thanks again for to play
magnets for letting me take a look at
that app and best of luck with your own
tactics all
[Music]
[Music]